this is the mother from the family
channel eight passengers she recently
got arrested for child abuse now many
point to old clips from her Vlog saying
it was obvious something was going on
all along well here is previous clips
that surfaced I guess when people
started noticing something was off about
this family so here is uh the mom Eve
did not pack a lunch today and can I
bring a lunch over to the
schools quite often when you're having
raising
chill I know that her teacher is
uncomfortable with her being hungry and
not having lunch and it would ease her
discomfort if I came to the school with
lunch but I I responded and just said
Eve is responsible for making her
lunches in the morning and she actually
told me she did pack a lunch so the
natural outcome is she's just going to
need to be hungry and hopefully nobody
gives her food and nobody steps in and
gives her a lunch